another crackdown in the heart of the
Capitol police detaining protesters
outside the federal headquarters of
utter Pradesh state people condemned the
killing of 18 demonstrators there in the
past few days the Delhi protesters said
they wanted to give a voice to people in
Portal Pradesh where the internet
remains cut off in many parts and large
gatherings are banned elsewhere in the
capital a similar outcry and defiant
mood on display at Jamia Millia Islamia
University while the university is a
Muslim institution the demonstrations
are attracting people from all walks of
life including first-time protesters
people have come out on the streets to
express their anger and they're saying
that the way this government has brought
this bill is undemocratic rupal de Barco
joined thousands who chanted against the
government and a citizenship law passed
by MPs on December the 11th the
citizenship Amendment Act makes it
easier for migrants from Afghanistan
Bangladesh and Pakistan to gain
citizenship but Muslims are excluded
students and civil society groups have
been a driving force for the protests so
far the main opposition Congress party
joined in with a sit-in at Raj Ghat a
memorial to Mahatma Gandhi the aim to
invoke the spirit of Gandhi's
inspirational campaign for civil rights
this constitution was drafted by people
of all faiths the voices of Hindus
Muslims Sikhs and Christians is an
integral part of the Constitution and
you cannot attack it and if you do the
nation will stop healing elsewhere in
India more large protests thousands
marched in the southern cities of
Chennai Bengaluru and Hyderabad
despite the largest protests against his
government since he was first elected
five years ago Prime Minister Narendra
Modi isn't backing down from the new law
insisting it isn't divisive
but he is backtracking on plans to hold
a National Register of citizens which
would require all Indians to prove their
citizenship that's not enough for his
critics
[Music]
[Music]